>>Ann: We're going to do a quick
little number talk, faces forward.
If you could put your fist
at your belly, please.
Everybody's fist at their belly.
>>Dr Cantor: In every classroom,
there are a few kids whose
hands will go up every second.
So this teacher has figured out
a way, by having a subtle signal,
to be able to encourage participation
from larger numbers of
kids in the class.
>>Ann: Everybody have
fist at their belly?
>>Ann: I don't want kids
raising their hands.
Some kids think faster than others,
but that doesn't mean that the kids
that aren't as fast don't understand.
They could be processing slower.
They could be looking at
it in a different way.
There are multiple reasons.
With raising of the hands, as soon as
kids see that person who's very fast
at answering a question, the rest of
the kids question say, "That's great.
I don't need to anymore.
I don't need to worry about that."
>>Ann: We're going to do a percentage
talk, if you even have an entry point
into the problem, something
to contribute to the problem,
you're going to put your thumb up, okay?
>>Ann: So I started by
putting a problem on the board.
>>Ann: So about a minute to think and
then as soon as you have some kind
of something to contribute
your thumb is going up.
>>Anisa: She'll say fist at the belly.
Then when you know the
answer or you have a clue how
to get the answer you put your thumb up.
>>Ann: I'm looking for those thumbs.
>>Cristo: It changes the mood.
Her classroom's a good environment.
I feel like I'm open to
give my opinion in anything.
>>I see some thumbs up.
Okay, can somebody help me with
the entry point over on that side?
>>Student: I know that half of
160 is 80, that's 50 percent.
>>Ann: Ati?
>>Ati: Oh, 10 percent is 16.
>>Ann: How do you know that?
>>Ann: You need instructional
strategies and routines
that allow everybody an entry point,
particularly at the beginning
of the class.
If you have something where the kids
are feeling like, "Oh, this is great,
I participated today, I contributed
something today," then they go
on to their next task, you
have them a little bit more
than you would otherwise.
>>Student: Fifty percent is eighty,
twenty-five percent is forty.
>>Ann: So what did we do with the
50 percent and the 25 percent?
>>Student: You add.
>>Ann: You're adding it, right.
>>Dr Cantor: By having
this more subtle signal,
this teacher is encouraging
participation from people
who might be reticent, and
enabling many more children
to participate in a discussion.
>>Student: To get 25 percent
you have to divide 50 by 2.